hello everyone welcome to another tunnel
technique class at home
i hope you are all doing very well today
we will work on our free leg
to improve the quality of each movement
because
in technique classes usually we focus a
lot on balance
and on the standing leg and the three
leggeds have been neglected and that's a
pity because your free leg is extremely
important
because it carries the whole
expressivity of your lungs
if you think about it the standing leg
is quite limited
in the number of movements it can do
because it's holding your weight
so it can basically bend or stretch
or pivot to change your direction
or to push the floor in order to move
your torso
in some direction for the next step but
your free leg moves from one point
to another in order to do a step and
the quality of the movement that you use
to move the leg from one point to
another
can express a lot about your emotions
even your
musicality and your dance in general
even your style
for example if you move the leg fast or
slow
or sharp or smooth or
fluid or cut yeah the free leg
can also adorn in the way from one point
to another
and we have a whole range of movements
that we can use
as adornments you can abort on the floor
you can alert on your own
standing leg you can learn on the air
you can even learn on the leg of the
partner
as well and the free leg can also
interact with the leg of your partner
for example in galchus
or in caresses or touches or pasadas or
unity so the free leg can do
a lot and if you think about
for example when you watch a couple
dancing yeah
usually your eyes go to whatever is
moving
to where the movement is and you don't
know more often than not that's the
freedom of the dancers and that's what
you follow
so your free leg is what captures the
attention
of whoever is looking and what can
even define your style of dancing yeah
just the free leg so it makes sense to
work on
the movements of the feeling so in
today's class we will start with our
warm up like always
and then we will do a series of
that will use the simplest movement that
your fila can do
which is an oscillation like this like a
pendulum
and we will combine this pendulum with
our knee
in order to find different variations of
this movement
yeah so okay let's go for the warm up
okay warm up so as always we start with
our feet together and i always recommend
to start with a few seconds
of just breathing deeply and slowly
and finding the center and imagining
that your weight is just coming
down towards the floor yeah just feel
the pressure of the feet on the floor
and imagine your weight going down yeah
okay and then we start with
shoulder rotation so we relax the arms
and we rotate the shoulders like this
yeah with the weight
and one two
three four
five six
seven and eight you have
them big and slow
okay and then we continue with circles
with the arms yeah so remember to keep
the elbows
always straight when the arms are up try
to keep your shoulders down
yeah and when you open the arms then
try to move the hands behind the back
so that you stretch the chest muscles
okay
and we do eight yeah slowly one
two
three four
five six
relax the shoulders seven
keep the elbow straight and eight
okay now we stretch the side of the
torso so we raise one arm make sure that
is straight and pointing up
and then slide with the hand down your
leg
until you can touch your knee or past
the knee
yeah and then hold the stretch for a few
seconds
and then pull yourself straight again
and then drop the arm and do it to the
other side okay
so we will do it four times to each side
so
raise the arm and then one go down
hold the stretch
and up and
one go down
hold the stretch
and up and two
go down on the stretch
up and two
go down hold the stretch
and up three
up and three
go down hold the stretch
up and the last one on this side
and up and the last one on the other
side
go down hold the stretch
and up okay good now we open the
legs a little bit yeah
we bend the knees slightly make sure
that the hip
is straight and going down yeah
not back or front straight and then make
a circle with the arms
and we rotate the torso left and right
remember to move the arms
and the torso together as one block
instead of moving the arms alone yeah
one block and during the movement you
keep the hip
and the head looking forward okay and we
do it twice
eight times to each side yeah so let's
start
one two
three four
five six
seven eight eight more
one two
three four
[Music]
five six seven
and eight okay now we stretch the knees
we grab the hips and then we bend
forwards keeping the back straight until
the back is parallel
with the floor yeah and then you will
feel a light stretch
on the back of your leg of your upper
leg
and then from here we keep going down
we let our hand our head hand and then
we bounce three times
back bounce bounce and then
we raise slowly until we are
vertical okay and we do it eight times
so let's start go forward parallel to
the floor
and then go down bounce bounce
bounce very relaxed and then up
one two down
bounce bounce bounce
and up three
parallel floor down bounce bounce
bounce and up
four go down
[Music]
and up very relaxed yeah
six go down bounce
bounce bounce and up
seven go down bounce
and eight go down bounce
bounce bounce and
up okay then we do circles with the hips
so
we move our hip back then we move it to
the
side yeah remember to keep the legs
straight the heels on the floor
and the head always on the center yeah
then
forward then to the other side and then
back okay
make the circle as big as you can yeah
really big
we do eight times one direction and then
we change the direction and do
eight times again yeah so let's go
one big circle to
three four
five six
seven and eight
and then eight more in the other
direction one
two three
four five
six seven
and eight okay then
straight again we close our legs we make
our
feet parallel with each other really
together
with no space between them knees also
you can also grab your hips if you want
and then we bend the knees
really low yeah and bounce three times
really relaxed
bounce balance balance and then we
stretch the knees
and we go up
on the toes and we hold this position
for a few seconds
yeah make sure that your core is tight
yeah and that your
foot joint is locked so you can hold
this position
okay and then we go down slowly don't go
down fast
yeah go down slowly and we do it eight
times
one bounce bounce bounce
stretch and up hold it
down bounce bounce pass
and up hold it
and down three bounce bounce bounce
stretch go up hold it
and down four bounce bounce bounce
and down five pounds
bounce bounce stretch go up
hold it and down
six bounce bounce bounce
stretch go up hold it
and down seven marks bounce
bounce go up hold it
go down and eight bounce bounce
bounce stretch go up
hold it and down
okay good now let's go for the first
exercise
okay as we have been doing in the latest
videos we will do each exercise twice
first we support on the wall and
then on our own balance yeah uh
you should really try not to depend too
much on the wall when you work
for me the wall is like these two little
wheels that you put at the back of a
bicycle
of a child that is learning to ride yeah
these wheels are not supposed to stay
there forever at some point when the
child
feels more comfortable you take them off
and then you just ride the bike so the
wall is the same
yeah at some point when you feel more
comfortable with the exercise more
secure
you let go of the wall and you work on
your own and the reason to do it this
way
is that if you can do an exercise on
your own
on your own balance then when you dance
with your partner
you will be able to do whatever
movements you practice
in a way that doesn't disturb the
partner at all
because you can do them on your own and
also
when it comes to the partner and you
have that small support
you will be able to do the movements
very easy because you can do them on
your own yeah
so that's the idea now the exercise is
very simple
i will show you from the profile because
it's easier to understand what's
happening with the legs yeah
so you put yourself profile from the
wall
so you will support yourself only with
one hand yeah just the fingers
and you put your weight on the leg that
is closer to the wall
so you will work with the outside leg
yeah
and the idea of the exercise is very
simple
it is to swing your leg back and forth
using only the hip so you will keep the
knee straight
at all times when it's going forward and
when it's going back the knees always
straight
yeah and you don't need to go very high
with the leg
because that's not the point the point
is to
use the weight of the free leg in order
to do the movement using as little force
as possible yeah very relaxed
and without force because you are using
the weight
of the of the leg yeah that's the idea
and we won't use metronome today because
the point is not to follow a specific
tempo or a specific music
but just to find this relaxed
quality of movement and to repeat it
many times yeah because the movement is
so
simple we will do it on each leg
32 times so we will count
to eight four times okay
and i will always count when i go
forward
so it will be and one and
two and three and so on okay
so let's start with the first side
support on the wall very light just the
fingers
put your weight on the leg that is close
to the wall
and let's work with this leg and
one two three
four five six
seven eight one
two three four
five six seven
eight one two
three four five
six seven eight
one two three
four five six
seven eight okay remember that the point
is to move the leg
as relaxed as possible yeah as relaxed
as possible
and one last tip before we change to the
other side
i will show you from the front when you
swing the leg
try that when the leg is going back that
the leg doesn't
open to the side doesn't open diagonally
yeah this is a natural tendency and the
leg has to open
a bit to the side so try to avoid that
yeah
if you have a mirror in front of you
it's great because then you can control
that your leg
is moving really forward and back
in a straight line without opening
okay good so now let's do the other side
yeah get ready
and one two
three four five
six seven eight
one two three
four five six
seven eight one
two three four
five six seven
eight one two
three four five
six seven eight
okay good now we change side again
and we do it without the wall so you can
put your arms
however you prefer yeah you can put them
in down embrace
or you can make a circle in front of you
yeah
or you can grab your hips if you want or
you can have the arms
down at your sides however is better for
you
for me for balance i prefer to make
a circle with my arms in front of me not
very high
low yeah below the chest so i will do
this
yeah okay so put your weight on one leg
and let's start
one two three
four five six
seven eight one
two three four
five six seven
eight one two
three four five
six seven eight
one two three
four five six
seven eight
okay remember don't bend the knee yeah
lay straight all the time okay let's do
this side so get ready
um one two
three four five
six seven eight
one two three
four five six
seven eight one
two three four
five six seven
eight one two
three four five
six seven eight
okay great so let's go to the next
exercise
okay the next exercise will be very
similar to the one before
so profile from the wall the weight
on the leg that is closer to the wall
and you will swing the free leg but
every time that the leg goes back
you will allow your knee to bend
so that the foot goes up like this yeah
the foot goes up behind you
notice that i don't say you have to bend
your knee
because if i say that you might do it
using force
you will bend your knee with force and
that's not what you should do you should
um use the weight of the foot
to bend the knee imagine that you have a
weight attached to the foot and your
foot is heavy
yeah and by using this weight
when you swing this weight the knee
bends by itself
the only thing you need to do is to keep
your knee
relaxed yeah and also keep
your foot joint relaxed so that
the foot points when it goes up
yeah like this so like before
we will do it first with supporting the
wall uh with the fingers
both legs and then without support both
legs okay
so let's do it eight times repeat it
four times
with the first leg okay so get ready
and let's go and one
two three four
five six seven
eight one two
three four five
six seven eight
one two three
four five six
seven eight one
two three four
five six seven
eight okay now we do the elevator
uh you don't have to rush in the swing
yeah you don't have to do it very fast
that's not the point the point is to do
it relaxed
yeah um later when you uh practice it on
your own
you can you will just find your speed
yeah
just let the leg swing free yeah okay
that's the point
so let's do this leg now
and one two
three four five
six seven eight
one two three
four five six
seven eight one
two three four
five six seven
eight one two
three four five
six seven eight
okay now we will do it without the wall
uh so now you have to really grab the
floor
with your standing foot yeah just grab
it
and push the floor down with your
standing leg
engage your core yeah make it tight
and make sure that your head is straight
and
on top of the hip yeah then you're not
like this
or something is not aligned yeah
try to stay straight and you can have
your arms
anywhere you want you could have them in
downward breaths like this if you want
like this for the woman or you could
make a circle in front of you
or you can grab your hips or you can
have your arms down
that's a bit strange but anyway you can
do that also if you want
it's up to you for myself i like to make
a circle
not very high just below the chest
so i'll do it like this but if you feel
more comfortable with embrace that's up
to you
okay so let's do this leg
on our own balance and
one two three
four five six
seven eight one
2 3 4
5 6 7
8 1 2
3 4 5
six seven eight
one two three
four five six
seven eight okay now
change sides grab the floor with a
standing foot
make sure that you're straight a little
bit leg now
and one two
three four five
six seven eight
one two three
four five six
seven eight one
two three four
five six seven
eight one two
three four five
six seven eight
okay good let's go to the next exercise
okay next exercise is going to be like
this
you swing the leg like you did before
but instead of bending the knee
when the leg is going back now you will
bend the knee
when the leg is going forward like this
yeah so you will raise
the knee more or less until the upper
leg is
parallel with the floor or until the
inertia of the movement
finishes naturally yeah whatever is more
comfortable for you
so when the leg is going back the knee
is straight
yeah you just use the hip and when the
leg is going forward you raise the leg
like this
okay and to help the movement to help
you do the movement
apart from this support on the wall you
will put also
your other hand in front of you like
this
more or less at the level of your hip
maybe a bit below
yeah and you will hit the hand with your
knee
yeah this is good because this is a
reference this will give you a target
to hit yeah and it will help you do the
movement
correctly and make sure that you're
moving the knee in front of you
yeah so the exercise look like looks
like as you swing back the leg is
straight you swing forward you bend the
knee
like this yeah okay so let's do it now
with this leg
just the fingers on the wall eight times
repeated four times
put this reference here and let's go
and one two
three four five
six seven eight
one two three
four five six
seven eight one
two three four
five six seven
eight one two
three four five
six seven
eight okay now change sides
finger on the wall you can put just one
finger that's great
yeah it's very light support
and then the reference in front of you
and
let's go huh one
two three four
five six seven
eight one two
three four five
six seven eight
one two three
four 5 6
7 8 1
2 3 4
5 6 seven
eight okay good now we will do it
on our own so without the support on the
wall
and also without the reference yeah just
put your arms symmetrically or in
embrace or in your hips
yeah but the movement of the free leg
should be the same
as before yeah the reference is just to
build muscle memory
where the knee is going but then you
should be able to go there
on your own without any reference okay
and one thing sorry just one more tip
when you move the leg forward
yeah try not to bend the torso
yeah don't do something like this
like this your leg should move
completely independently from the torso
your torso should not move
at all yeah only the leg
okay so let's do it on our own
with this leg get ready
and one two
[Music]
three four five
six seven eight
one two three
four five six
seven eight one
two three four
five six seven
eight one two
three four five
six seven eight
okay now let's change sides and do it
with the other leg
yeah remember push the floor with your
standing leg
grab the floor with the foot keep your
torso straight at all times
head on top of the hip and core engaged
yeah and just relax the free leg
trust the movement and use the weight of
the leg
to swing in a very relaxed way okay
so let's do it together ah
one two
three four
five six
seven eight one
two three four
five six seven
eight one two
three four five
six seven eight
one two three
four five six
seven eight
okay great let's go to the next
exercise okay the next exercise will be
a combination of the previous two
so you will swing your leg from the hip
and you will bend the knee when the leg
is going
back and when the leg is going forward
so both
yeah both sides like this
yeah now remember that the
point is to make a very relaxed
movement yeah so that means that
between this position when the knee is
bending back and between this position
when the knee is bent forward you have
to let
your leg pass through zero yeah
when you go back and the foot
the weight of the foot bends the knee
the leg drops and passes through you
yeah and then after you bend the knee
forward
the leg drops again yeah drops and goes
behind
yeah and when you drop the leg like this
yeah you drop it on zero position
the leg bounces back yeah when you throw
the leg down
you let it drop you have a rebound
rebound
rebound rebound yeah and this will help
you
make uh have a very relaxed movement
yeah you can take advantage of these
physics to help your movement yeah
so that's important let the food
let the leg drop and then take advantage
of the rebound
when you drop the leg okay so
first we will do it with support on the
wall with the fingers
and with the other hand as a reference
for the knee in front of us okay
so let's do it eight times repeat that
four times with this leg
so make sure you are straight get ready
and one two
three four five
six seven eight
one two three
four five six
seven eight one
two three four
five six seven
eight one two
three four five
six seven
eight yeah try not to depend too much on
the wall
yeah it's very light let's do it on this
side now
so get ready grab the floor with the
standing foot
just the fingers and in front of you
and let's go and
one two three
four five six
seven eight one
two three four
five six seven
eight one two
three four five
six seven eight
one two three four
five six seven
[Music]
eight okay now
we will decide again but
without the wall and without the
reference
yeah so now it's very important to
grab the floor with your standing foot
make sure you are straight
core is engaged heavies on top of the
hips
arms have to stabilize and then relax
the leg as much as you can
okay so get ready and let's go
and one two three
four five six
seven eight one
two three four
five six seven
eight one two
three seven four five
six seven eight
one two three
four five six
seven eight okay
now it's inside
and we'll decide now so we are ready
prepare the leg find a point in front of
you
yeah that you can look at all the time
and fix your gaze and look at it as a
reference also
this also helps a lot to find a point
exactly on your horizon
in front of you and focus on that point
while you exercise
okay let's do it together on
one two three
four five six
seven eight one
two three four
five six seven
eight one two
three four five
six seven eight
one two three
four five six
seven eight
okay good if you get tired
take a break and then you can continue
with the video
whenever you feel like okay let's go to
the next exercise
okay in this exercise we will introduce
a new element
which is crossing the leg yeah so
you start in zero position and when the
leg is swinging back
you bend the knee you use the foot to
bend your knee
then the leg drops and passes through
zero
and swings forward when you swing
forward you don't need to raise the knee
now
we don't use that yeah you just let the
foot go forward
like this with the knee straight and
then when the foot swings back
you go to the other side and then
you bend the knee yeah or actually the
knee will bend by itself
yeah and then after the cross you let
your foot swing forward again and then
you return to this position
so the exercise looks like this
yeah you go back front cross
front back front cross front
back front cross front like this okay
now uh when you cross the
the leg like this you need to bend the
knee
by yourself you need to bend the knee
explicitly with force the knee will bend
by itself
because the leg is hitting
or touching your standing leg and the
foot wants to continue the movement
yeah think for example about this
movement
yeah i swing my arm and at some point
my arm collides with this obstacle
but because the hand has inertia from
before the hand wants to continue the
movement
yeah and this results in my elbow
bending
i'm not bending my elbow explicitly it
just happens
because of the obstacle yeah the hand
wants to continue the movement with the
inertia that comes from before
and the hand is bending by elbow so it's
the same thing here
yeah when the leg swings forward now the
foot
is going to swing back like a pendulum
yeah the pendulum is what we are using
all the time so when it swings back
eventually
it touches the leg touches the standing
leg and the standing leg is an obstacle
and the inertia of the foot makes that
the foot wants to continue the movement
and this results in the knee bending you
see
so your knees be is being bent by the
inertia of the foot
not by your muscles bending the knee
okay
that's important is the same here
yeah the weight of your foot has inertia
and is bending your knee okay this will
help you
to achieve a really relaxed efficient
and beautiful movement okay so we don't
need the reference here because we are
not using this
we just need to support on the wall with
the fingers okay
so let's do it eight times repeat it
four times
so get ready make sure you are straight
prepare the leg and let's go
and one two three
four five six
seven eight one
two three four
five six seven
eight one two
three four five
six seven eight
one two three
four five six
seven eight okay now let's change sides
do it with the other leg support on the
one
prepare your standing leg find your
posture find your center
and let's go and one
two three four
five six seven
eight one two
three four five
six seven eight
one two three
four five six
seven eight one
two three four five
six seven eight
okay now let's turn again
and this week without support from the
wall
so press the floor with your standing
leg grab the floor with the foot
engage your core make sure your head is
on top of your hips
place your arms prepare the leg relax it
trust the movement and let's go
and one two
three four five
six seven eight
one two three
four five six
seven eight one
two three four
five six seven
eight one two
three four five
six seven eight
okay now turn and let's go
the other leg prepare your position
first the foot the leg the torso the
head
the arms relax your free leg
and let's go and one
two three four
five six seven
eight one two
three four five
six seven eight
one two three
four five six
seven eight one
two three four
five six seven
eight okay
great very good so we are ready to go
to the last exercise okay before we go
into the last exercise if you're doing
the whole thing
uh non-stop um be careful with your
lower back
because when you practice a lot standing
especially moving the leg like this
you might be compressing the lower back
a little bit so i recommend you to take
a break
every now and then and then just
bend your back like this forward
yeah and then if you can just continue
bending
until your head is hanging and just
bounce a little bit yeah
just to relax this part of your back
yeah
uh with the exercise can become a little
bit tight yeah you can also do it with
the
hands behind your head as we do on the
warm-up yeah
and just do a little bit like this yeah
balance a bit
yeah relax the lower leg let it stretch
yeah a few seconds and then go up slowly
[Music]
and then you're ready to continue okay
so
in the last exercise we will throw
everything we have done
until now into it so the sequence is
like this
you start from zero position when the
leg is swinging back
your knee is going to bend like this
yeah like before
one then when the leg is dropping down
to zero position yeah you drop it there
is this rebound
boom and this rebound helps you to
raise the knee and you will touch your
hand with the knee like we did before
yeah then from here you drop
the leg and you go into the cross
yeah the rebound goes into the cross
as soon as the free leg touches the
standing leg
which is an obstacle the inertia of the
foot will make
that the knee bends by itself then when
the foot is swinging back
from the cross yeah then it goes forward
and you raise the knee again and then
from here
you drop the leg again it goes in zero
position
and then the rebound goes into this
position again
and then you repeat the whole thing okay
so the exercise
slowly looks like this yeah back
knee close knee back
knee close knee okay so now
it's not only about swinging your leg in
a relaxed way it's also a bit about
coordination
yeah between hip and knee and cross
all together and this will help you a
lot later when in your dance you try
complex alignments
which we will do in another video okay
so let's get ready prepare your position
foot leg torso head just the fingers on
the wall
and then your other hand here as a
reference and let's look with this leg
eight times repeated four times
so relax your free leg and let's go
and one two
3 4 5
6 7 8
1 2 3
4 5 six
seven eight one
two three four
five six seven
eight one two
three four five
six seven eight
okay now change sides with this
fingers on the wall find your position
[Music]
relax the leg prepare the hand
and let's go ah one
two three four
five six seven
eight one two
three four 5
6 7 8
1 2 3
4 5 6
7 eight one
two three four
five six seven
eight okay good
now we do it again without the wall
and without the reference so completely
on our
own so now it's really important
that you really find your axis
and your position and you engage the
core and you concentrate
on a point in front of you because the
free leg is going to do
a lot yeah so you should try not to lose
your balance
okay so grab the floor with your
standing foot
press the floor down with the leg engage
your core
make sure you are straight and then the
head is on top of your hips
place your arms which will help for
balance
prepare the free leg relax it
and let's go and one
two three four
five six seven
eight one two
three four five
six seven eight
one two three
four five six
seven eight one
two three four five
six seven eight
okay good now we change sides
and one last tip is if
uh you find it really difficult to keep
your balance
when you do all this stuff with the leg
there is a trick that works for me which
is that
there is this moment where your knees
forward like this
yeah which comes after this and after
this so for me
this is the riskiest position of the
whole
exercise yeah so what i do is that
when my leg reaches this position i
really try to focus on my balance here
yeah on my posture and my alignment
and my balance yeah so at this moment
when the knee goes
up i press the floor
with the standing leg extra yeah
one i press the floor down as the knee
is going up
i press down yeah and i erase the cord
and if i manage to keep my balance on
this position
then the other positions are easier yeah
when the leg is going back this is
easier and when the leg is crossing
it's easier so focus on your balance on
this position when the knee is going
up in front of you yeah so it would be
like
a balance balance
present floor present floor and so on
okay hopefully these little tricks these
little hacks
help you to do the whole exercise uh
without
falling down okay so
get ready press the floor engage the
core
place your head place the arms relax the
leg
and let's go for it
one two three
four five six
seven eight one
two three four
five six seven
eight one two
three four five
six seven eight
one two three
four five six
seven eight
okay so that was it that was the whole
uh class of the whole exercise so
now at the end of the class i always
like to explain how
does this help you in your dance well if
you have done the whole thing you should
feel it now in your legs how it helps
you
so um
for example it will help your walk
believe it or not even if you don't do a
single adornment
and you just walk these exercises will
help
why because walking yeah
is nothing more than moving your legs
your free leg
like a pendulum yeah when you do a step
the leg goes from back to front or from
front to back
like a pendulum
and pendulums are what you have been
doing the whole time
yeah so as you know pendulums have
dynamic
yeah imagine a a child on a swing
yeah a childhood swing when the swing
reaches the point of
maximum height that's when the swing is
going
at the slowest speed yeah it's very slow
and when the swing reaches the vertical
yeah
that's when the swing is going at the
maximum speed so it's going very fast
boom and then it slows down and then it
goes fast and it slows down
on the change of direction so pendulums
by themselves have dynamic the speed is
not constant
it changes it's slow and fast so
because these exercises are all based on
the idea of the pendulum this is the
basic movement
yeah then when you walk
and use this pendulum idea your work
will look very dynamic
the movement of the leg will start
slowly and then it will end fast
and it will look very relaxed because
you are used to swing your legs in a
very relaxed way
yeah and of course later if you
want to adorn or do gauchos or things
where the
knee has to bend and the foot has to go
up of course these exercises are
very effective to help you with that
of course you still have to practice
with
your partner if you are practicing
ganchos for example
because you still need to practice with
a partner that your leg goes
on the right spot at the right time yeah
but at least until that happens if you
do these exercises on your own
when you practice gum chews the the
movement of your leg will already be
very good it will be very relaxed
very efficient and very dynamic okay
so that's the point of this class okay i
hope it helped you
thank you very much for watching and
thank you for your support
for this channel and i will see you in
the next class
bye